hello there this is Steve I'm gonna do
an experiment here which I think you I
hope is working I'm going to do a video
and at the same time record the sound on
a on audio thing so I can also put an
audio file in there for those of you who
like to download audio and I'm going to
talk about output and I'm not gonna
provide any kind of transcript today
because I'm so busy
multitasking here video audio and I take
my glasses off so I don't get a
reflection that means that everything is
fuzzy that I'm looking at so I hope I've
done everything correctly but talking
about output here you know many of you
may know that I put a lot of emphasis on
input as a key method of learning for
example right now by the way this is
Stephen the linguist blogs calm alright
so right now in my Russian studies
mostly I'm just listening and I started
out listening to very easy things I had
someone translate the power of the
linguist which is a very simple story
that we have translate that into Russian
transcribe it I worked on that at link I
had other simple things but I listened
to 20 30 times I also before we had link
up and running I used help yourself and
colloquial Russian and anything I could
get my hands on
lots of listening and reading and saving
words when I got on the link of course I
was able to keep track of my of my words
and put them into a database review them
and I was also able to see that when I
started into Russian literature which I
tried to do within about three or four
months of starting Russian that
initially I would have 50 or 60 percent
unknown words in the Russian content so
it was very tough to work your way
through that I would take small bits of
it you know save these words review them
listen listen listen and go back and so
forth now I'm at the stage where a link
tells me that for most of the Russian
literature that I'm doing now whether it
be Tolstoy or Chekhov for Virginia it's
about 20 percent unknown words so you
know as long as I'm at that level that
mean
when I'm listening there's things that I
don't get when I read there's things
that I don't get I want to get it down
below 10% so when I've learned so many
words that I can pick up a piece of
Russian that capture or a news article
or whatever and and I have less than 10%
unknown words then I think I have
achieved the level where I can start
focusing on output more focusing on
grammar you know instead of reading for
meaning or listening for meaning and
noticing and saving words for meaning
I'll start saving phrases that contain
you know the different case changes and
other things that happen in Russian and
at that time I will do more talking and
and and and writing so you know what is
the role of output at an earlier stage I
believe it is still important at an
early stage not so much as a certainly
insofar as speaking is concerned not so
much as a as a opportunity to learn the
language but it serves other purposes
first of all it helps to keep you
motivated if you know you have to meet a
teacher like here at at link to you
having a an appointment with your tutor
next Tuesday or every Tuesday or twice a
week that helps to motivate you you
don't want to disappoint the tutor when
you are speaking you sort of come across
some of the things that you have trouble
saying so then you start to look for
those when you're listening and reading
so it forces you to prepare a little bit
I mean I believe that the writing is
more effective than speaking insofar as
finding problem areas in your language
because you have a record and it's
easier from a written text specially the
way we do it or we correct the writing
and we give you correct phrases and then
you can import this into link and you
can save the words that you didn't use
correctly and treat that as as learning
content so the writing is pretty
important but also is the speaking even
though when you direct people when they
speak they tend to repeat the same error
over and over again it's it's
nevertheless it's an exercise it's a
challenge it shouldn't be too much done
too much and the big thing is one
shouldn't think or hope that
just having conversations is going to
teach you the language for a variety of
reasons first of all it's very difficult
to have a conversation just for the sake
of having a conversation with someone
that you aren't necessarily interested
in having a conversation with so okay
what did you do on the weekend what do
you think the global warming you know
when your once you've gone through a few
of these there's no much stuff to talk
about if you don't have a genuine
interest in communicating or in having a
conversation and it's made all the more
difficult because you're doing in a
foreign language so a little bit of
talking once or twice a week writing
once or twice a week a major focus on
input until you reach a stage where your
comprehension both listening
comprehension and your ability to enjoy
reading in a language have become so
strong that now you are ready to take
what you have built up and move into the
output and and I believe that at that
time if you if you've emphasized the
input and the listening and the reading
you'll have a strong vocabulary you'll
be more confident you'll have better
pronunciation then if you were to do it
the traditional way by the traditional
right way I mean trying to remember
everything that's in Chapter one trying
to say it right trying to do the
exercises then once you've mastered
Chapter one you go to chapter two or
sitting in a classroom with 20 people
all of whom speak the language that
you're studying very poorly so that what
you are immersed in is not the language
as spoken by native speakers with real
meaning and real content but a lot of
people stumbling like you which I think
is is a very very low intensity language
environment so to sum up output is
important even at an early stage even
though from a learner's perspective the
emphasis initially should be on
understanding reading and listening and
building up vocabulary and getting used
to the language but even in that early
stage as soon as you feel up to it once
or twice a week to challenge yourself
initially one-on-one because you don't
speak well enough to sit in a group you
would just annoy them and embarrass
yourself and eventually and we notices
with our link learners after six months
or so
one then getting a group three or four
on one and do that once or twice a week
and also take the time to write because
that's where you really pick up on where
your structural problems are and and
that helps you them to look for those
kinds of words and phrases and
structures in the language as you're
listening and reading so a very quick
discussion then on the place for output
and and I guess the key thing there is
to not feel inadequate because you
aren't able to say something early and I
don't agree with with the people who say
that you only need 800 words and you can
be fluent or no you can't or if you if
you master five phrases to use at the
bank and another five phrases to use at
the restaurant that you'll be ok yeah
that might work if your goal is to go
down to Mexico and hope to be able to
say buenos dias to a few people but if
you want to learn a language that just
is not going to do it so I believe in
that initial input phase silent phase
then followed by a much stronger output
phase and at that point you'll feel much
more confident with your output now I
have to put my glasses on again to see
how to turn this thing off and thank you
very much for listening